ادوس على ايه ادوس على
احنا لايف
مساء الخير على حضراتكم
ليله سعيده ان شاء الله ربنا يجعل كل
ايامكم سعيده وكل سنه وحضراتكم طيبين
انا في انتظار اسئله حضراتكم واظن ان
بعضها وصل بالفعل
اول صديق محمد عطوان بيقول هل انت اه اعمل
هل انت مع مقوله ان حكم الاخوان هو
المسؤول عن ازمه سد النهضه في مصر ام هو
كما تدعي المعارضه مجرد محاوله من العسكر
للتغطيه على فشلهم وفسادهم
هو ازمه سد النهضه دي بدات اولا
الاثيوبيين بيحاولوا يعملوا السد من
الستينات فده يعني سد
بنفس المواصفات دي بس كان على نطاق اصغر
شويه من الستينات ودائما كان في معارضه
مصريه اساس السد انه كان موازين القوه
كانت دايما في صالح مصر
فمنعت اثيوبيا
بالضغط والقوه من بناء هذا السد
اللي حصل ابريل 2011 لكن في اخوان ولا غير
اخوان ولكن كانت مصر كلها مشغوله في
الاحداث الضخمه جدا للربيع العربي
اللي انتهت طبعا بتنحم مبارك وفراغ سياسي
لفتره جاء بعده الاخوان لفتره لا صعب طبعا
ان انت تحمله للاخوان او لغيرهم ولكن
تحمله للحظه ضعف موجوده في الدوله المصريه
بسبب انشغالها وانكفائها على نفسها بسبب
الاحداث اللي حصلت وعليه فاللي حصل انه
الاثيوبيين
استغلوا انشغال الدوله المصريه
بمشاكلهم الداخليه وبداوا في السد لكن في
مشكله تانيه الحقيقه يعني
انه كتير من النخب المصريه ده انا لمستوا
بنفسك صحفي يعني كانوا مختلفين فيما بينهم
هل السد خطير جدا الى درجه ان الدوله لازم
تتحرك فورا هل هو
مضر تماما لمصر ولا
له بعض الفوائد هل يمكن التفاهم مع
الاثيوبيين بدون استخدام قوه خشنه يعني
كان في اختلاف والاختلاف ده اجل ان مصر
تاخد موقف حازم في الوقت المناسب فعندك
العاملين انشغال مصر به الظروف الداخليه
والامر التاني طبعا هو
يعني اختلاف النخب المصريه على الموقف من
السد
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله استاذ سيد رمضان
مبارك ربنا يخليك معك مروان من السعوديه
هل برايكم ستخذوا الصين تايوان واذا نعم
متى تعتقدون سيحدث ذلك يا اخونا مروان هذا
اللي بيسموه
دولار
القصه فعلا في سؤال على فكره انا كان من
ضمن الحلقات الكثيره اللي انا حطيتها على
هذا الجهاز ودائما باجلها يعني
لماذا تتردد الصين في غزوه تايوان
القصه لها جوانب كثيره واحد منها طبعا
الصين ترغب في غزوه تايوان منذ عام
1949 يعني من بعد هروب القوميين بعد
هزمتهم امام الشيوعيين في الحرب الاهليه
في الصين الى الجزيره بعيدا عن البر
فالفكره دائما قائمه من سنه 49 ومن سنه 49
في مجموعه من الاعتبارات بتجعل الصين تحجم
وتتردد عن عمليه الغزو واحد من الاسباب
الرئيسه طبعا في البدايه كان انشغال
الصينيين بمشاكل تانيه كثيره انتصروا في
الحرب واجلوا القضيه دي شويه لكن كان
دايما في السبب هو خوف الصينيين ان هاجمه
تايوان ان يهزموا تايوان دوله قويه على
عكس ما يعتقد الكثيرون وكانوا خايفين من
ان هم يهزموا الصين ما كانش عندها جيش قوي
يستطيع ان يطيح يعطيها الثقه في هزيمه
التايوان او في حسم صراعتها مع دول عندها
مشاكل حدوديه كتيره منها اليابان مثلا
وكان دايما في تقدير انه لقى احنا مش
جاهزين كفايه
كمان تكون
استنفذت كل الوسائل الاخرى ايه الوسائل
الاخرى ما تيوائل الصين بتحاول ان هي تضم
تايوان هي بتعلن ان هي في نهايه المضاف في
كل الاحوال سوف تضمها سوف تضمها سواء
بالسلم او بالقوه لكن مين وايل في الاثناء
هي بتحاول تعمل كل حاجه من ضمن الحاجات
اللي بتعملها الصين على مدار عشرات
السنوات اللي تخلي الاقتصاد التايواني
على الاقتصاد الصيني الى 24 مليون تايواني
ما يتنفسوش الا بالاقتصاد الصيني انه تدعم
كل الطيارات
ومنها الطيار الحزب اللي هو يعني بني على
القوميين اللي هاجروا
خسروا الحرب يعني في سنه 49 انه يكونوا
مؤيدين للعوده للصين مره اخرى
وتسعين كان في تفاهم ان احنا خلاص جزء من
الصين وما فيش اي مشاكل
فهي كانت بتعتمد على وسائل كثيره
خلتها تحت اجل فكره الحسم العسكري
طبعا ردا على سؤالك متى يعني ما حدش يقدر
يجيب على السؤال ده طول الوقت الامريكان
والاوروبيين بيضعوا السيناريوهات لكن
دايما الصين
بتوازن اعتباراتها الداخليه وتشوف ايه
انسب لحظه ممكن تقوم فيها بهذه
بهذا الغزو اللي هيكون يعني حدث ضخم جدا
لماذا تسعى الدول العربيه في الطبيعه مع
الاسد ماذا يملك الاسد في سوريا والسيطره
الفعليه لروسيا وايران ده محمد محمد اي
دوله لان السؤال بيجي لي بساخ كتيره
معناها انه الاسد عنده دوله متداعيه انه
لا يسيطر بالكامل على سوريا اسئله كتيره
من النوع ده معناها انه مسك انت ما هواش
مهم قوي اي دوله مهما كانت صغيره
انك تكسب ودها او انك تبسط نفوذك عليها
بيكون مؤثر ومهم احنا شفنا دول اقل شانا
من بكثير من سوريا
ولما دول خسرت السيطره والنفوذ عليها
تضررت بشده يعني دول زي مثلا الصومال
الصومال لما العالم او دول اثارت ظهرها
ليها تحولت الى
بندوره بوكس دوله عندها ارض عندها مقدرات
عندها خيارات عندها موقع يمكن ان يستخدم
من قبل خصومك واعدائك دوله ممكن ان ينفذ
منها المهربى كل المواد الممنوعه
والارهابيين الى اخره انت بتقول سوريا
ممكن تقدم ايه سوريا يمكن ان تقدم الكثير
النهارده الوجود الروسي بيعتمد في شرعيته
على دعوه من الرئيس بشار الاسد النهارده
بشار الاسد لما يظهر عدم رغبته في وجود
الروس هتلاقي كل اعداء روسيا بيدعموه
وبيضغطوا على روسيا وبيعتبروا وجودها
احتلال فده يمثل ضغط شديد على الرؤوس نفس
القصه بالنسبه للايرانيين
بشار الاسد في المناطق التي يسيطر عليها
مؤثر لانه رئيس دوله عضوي في الجامعه
العربيه مؤثر على كل السبل هو يستطيع ان
يمنحك ان تحصل على قاعده عسكريه في سوريا
يستطيع ان يمنحك عقود الاعمار او يمنعها
عنك هو بدولته مثلا او بضعف دولته ادوا
الى مشاكل كثيره في المنطقه انا ما كنتش
اسمع يعني ايه الكبتاجون فوجئنا ان هذا
المخدر بيمثل مشكله كبيره لكثير من دول
المنطقه وخصوصا دول الخليج
وعائداته بمليارات الدولارات وبالتالي
سوريا
اي دوله تقدر تاثر سلبا او ايجابا لكن
سوريا كمان مهياش دوله يعني قليله
وبالتالي الكل حريص عليه وجزء اساسي قبل
كل الكلام اللي انا قلته ده انه كانت
الحزبه من قبل كده على مدار عشر سنوات
الفريق اللي اراد اسقاط بشار الاسد
اعتقد ان الوقت المناسب لاسقاطه وبالتالي
ضرب
النفوذ الايراني اللي هو متحالف معه هو
ووالده من سنه 79 والفريق اللي كان بيعارض
هذا هذا التوجه واللي زاد في الفتره
الاخيره واللي قادته الامارات والبحرين
ومصر كانوا بيقولوا ان هذا الاسلوب لم
يجدي نفعا وان احنا علينا ان احنا نتواصل
معه املين في انه تواصلنا معه يقلل من
حاجته للايرانيين ويقلل من حاجته للروس
وبالتالي الايرانيين العرب مهتمين
بالايرانيين مشكلتهم مع الروس يعني لكن في
دول تانيه مشغوله لان فوزي الروسي زي
الاتراك زي الامريكان زي الاوروبيين لو
تواصلنا مع الاسد يمكن ان يخفف ذلك من
ارتباطه بهذه الدول وبالتالي يقل نفوذهم
في سوريا
هل تؤدي التغيرات الثقافيه ده محمد اعتقد
هو نفسه محمد هل تؤدي التغيرات الثقافيه
الى تغيير سلوك الشركات ام سلوك الشركات
يؤدي الى التغيرات الثقافيه ده سؤال عميق
محمد انا مش قادر افهم
السؤال تقصد ايه لو توضح لي اكون شاكر
يعني
مروان انا مش متاكد من الاسم السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله استاذ سيد رمضان مبارك يا
كابتن السؤال ده مروان الا تعتقد ان
امريكا لا تستطيع ان تمارس ضغوطا هائله
الا تعتقد ان امريكا لا تستطيع ان تمارس
ضغوطا هائله على من ارادت ومن بينهم
الحلفاء وخصوصا دول الخليج الواقع ان اكبر
منتج للنفط في العالم مستفيد كثيرا
وبالمناسبه حرمه روسيا
حرمت روسيا بشكل كبير بسبب سقف السعر
سامحني يا علي انا مش فاهم السؤال اذا كنت
بتقول ان امريكا لا تستطيع ان تمارس ضغوطا
هائله على من ارادت
هي طبعا ما تقدرش هي بتمارس ضغوط بس هل
الضغوط ديت هي طول الوقت بتمارس ضغوط
كدوله كبيره تغض احيانا بتنجح واحيانا لا
في معيارين في مساله الضغوط في تصور عند
بعض الناس
تصور عام انه الدول الصغيره او الدول اللي
هي اقل يعني بالنسبه للدول العظمى زي
الدول العربيه انها دول تابعه للقوى
العظمى واحنا في الحاله دي بنتكلم على
الولايات المتحده وان لامريكا كل ما ارادت
ضد هذه الدول وفي ناس بيقولوا لا يعني
يقروا موقف او اتنين او بعض المذكرات
فيقولوا في بعض الزعماء طوال الوقت
بيتحدوا الولايات المتحده وعندهم ان يعني
سياده في قرارهم ولا يتدخل احد ابدا في
قراراتهم الحقيقه المساله بسيطه طوال
الوقت الولايات المتحده كقوه عظمى اذا
ارادت شيء في الغالب بتحصل عليه لكن هي
احيانا لا تضغط يعني مش بتمارس الضغط طوال
الوقت يعني ممكن تطلب شيء وتتقبل ان دوله
صديقه او قسم او يعني صنفها زي ما انت
عاوز ترفض لان المساله مش حيويه جدا
للولايات المتحده
على سبيل المثال اذا دوله ارادت ان هي
تشتري سلاحا روسيا وده بيخالف احد
القوانين الامريكيه ويا شايفه انه الدوله
ديت لا تمثل تهديد عليها وان شراء هذا
السلاح لن يغير من موازين القوه في
المنطقه اللي الدوله دي موجوده فيها خلاص
الولايات المتحده بتقول لها ما تشتريش
بتخض الطرف وبتتجاوز المساله يعني مش
نهايه الكون لكن تخيل ان الدوله دي ارادت
ان هي تطور سلاح نووي المساله دي بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده مساله خطيره جدا
وبالتالي بتمارس ضغوط كبيره جدا هنا بقى
هل الضغوط دي تفلح ولا لا يجي للشق التاني
من المساله ان في دول عندها اصرار كبير
جدا ومستعد لدفع فاتوره كبيره لمقاومه
الضغوط الامريكيه زي مين زي كثير زي الدول
اللي هي رفضت النفوذ الامريكي لكن دفعت
فاتوره عنيفه زي كوبا زي بنسويلا زي ايران
زي كوريا الشماليه
في دول بتقول طب المساله تستحق ترضخ لو
وجدت ان الضغوط الامريكيه مش عنيفه
بالنسبه لها او تقاوم لسنوات طويله ان
كانت الطلبات الامريكيه تتعارض بشكل جوهري
مع تصوراتها لانها القومي
الا تعتقد ان امريكا هل يكون نجاح منظمه
بريكس المسمار الاخير في نعش النظام القطب
الواحد ده محمد عطوان على فكره انا شايف
كتير في وسائل الاعلام العربيه كلام كتير
عن البريكس وعن تبني عمله بديله عن
الدولار انا مش عارف اصله جاي منين يعني
انا سامع حتى ماندو كان بيقول لي قبل
التذكير مباشره بيقول لي ان في حد عامل
حلقات او بيكتب او كذا او عنده عامل حلقات
يعني على يوتيوب وبيتكلم على العمله
الموحده لبريكس وانه دول مختلفه ومنها مصر
هتتبنى ما اعرفش اليوانه في كلام كثير
بيتقال الكلام بيخلوا من الدقه
حدود معلوماتي واظن المعلومات يعني
اعتقد ان هذا هو الصواب يعني موضوع
البريكس قصته كالاتي وفي حلقه عن البريكس
دول البريكس الخمسه اللي هو الصين وروسيا
وجنوب افريقيا والبرازيل والهند الدول
الخمسه دول منذ تاسيس البريكس
ومنذ انضمام اخر دوله في 2009 2010 اللي
هي جنوب افريقيا اللي هي اختصار اسامي
الحرف الاولاني باللغه الانجليزيه من
الدول الخامسه ديت كان احد
التحالف كله قام على فكره ان احنا كدول
ناميه وعندها فرص واعده للنمو نعمل تكتل
يقلل نفوذ الولايات المتحده علينا
وكان واحد من اهدافهم بعد ازمه
2008 و2009 انه الولايات المتحده بتجر
العالم الى ازمات ونكبات لا سيطره لنا
عليها وبالتالي عاوزين يبقى عندنا مساحه
استقلال اكبر اقتصاديا عن هذا القطب
العملاق اللي هو الولايات المتحده وكان
واحد من اهدافهم لتنفيذ هذه السياسه ان
يكون يعتمدوا اكتر على عملتهم المحليه مش
هيستغنوا عن الدولار تماما وقتها ولكن
يبداوا يزودوا تعاملاتهم بالعملات المحليه
الامثله على كده كتيره جدا
مثلا
الصين عاوزه تشتري الغاز الروسي
وروسيا عاوزه تشتري منتجات صينيه متعدده
فبيقولوا طيب احنا حجم التبادل بيننا
وليكن مثلا تريليون دولار ما يعادل
تريليون دولار يعني انت عاوز مني وانا
عاوز منك طب ونجيب الدولار بسيط ليه انا
هشتري منك باليوان مباشره وانت هتشتري مني
بالروبل مباشره وفي مصلحه وبين انه هنا هو
الناس ما بتاخدش عملات بعض ليه يعني تخيل
الوضع كالاتي بريطانيا بلاش بريطانيا
عاوزه دوله تكون منتجه شويه بالمانيا
عاوزه تشتري حاجه من المغرب او من مصر
هتيجي تشتري منها
هتشتري منها باليورو مصر او المغرب هتقبل
اليورو لانها تاخد اليورو ده وهتحتاج
تشتري به منتجات اخرى من المانيا او من
غيرها طيب العكس لو ان هي عاوزه
المانيا تيجي تشتري من يعني العكس معنى
ذلك ان المانيا لازم تدفع الاول تدفع جنيه
مصري او تدفع بالعمله المغربيه عشان تاخد
طب المانيا لما هتاخد العمله دي هتعمل بها
ايه مش هتعمل بها حاجه لان احتياجاتها
للشراء من المغرب او مصر محدوده لكن لو في
تواقت يعني توازن في تكافؤ ان عمليه
التجاره والتبادل بين مصر والمانيا بين
المغرب والمانيا زاد هتبقى هي محتاجه ان
هي تحوش الجنيه او تحوش الدينار وتحطه
عندها علشان تستخدمه في عمليات تجاريه
لاحقا المبدا بدا يزيد مع زياده
عمليات التجاريه بين دول البريكس وخصوصا
بعد
الحرب حرب اوكرانيا زادت بشكل كبير جدا
فبدا يقللوا اعتمادهم على الدولار
واستخدمهم للدولار في عمليات مختلفه بين
البرازيل والصين وبين الصين وجنوب افريقيا
وبين
الروبل الروسي مقابل الجنيه المصري بيحصل
ده لكن على نطاق صغير لانه حجم التعاملات
ما بين مصر وروسيا اولا هو لصالح روسيا
وما هواش كبير فالروس لو خدوا كميات كبيره
من الجنيه المصري مش هيستفيدوا بها وما
بياخدوا من الجنيه المصري بقدر ما يكفي
حجم الاحتياجاتهم من مصر كميه المنتجات
اللي بيشتروها بين مصر او السياحه بس كل
ما بتزيد حجم التجاره بيزيد حجم التعاملات
وهكذا ينطلق المساله على مصر والصين على
المغرب وروسيا وجنوب افريقيا وهكذا حتى
هذه اللحظه لا توجد عمله موحده للدول
الخمسه
وحتى الان في عمليات تجاريه بتزيد من دول
البريكس ودول البريكس ودول اخرى لكن لا
يوجد استغناء كامل عن الدولار ولا يوجد
حديث عن هذا اظن للسنوات المقبله مش عارف
اذا كنت انا كده وضحت ولا لخبطتكم ارجو
كانت الفكره مش واضحه نتناقش تاني
هل من الممكن ان تصمت حكومه اليمن في ظل
ده محمد في ظل عدم رضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
والولايات المتحده عنها
ما هو بقى ايه ايه حكومه اليمن معلش
الاسئله كلها ارجع تاني انا اسف اهو
هل من الممكن ان تصمت حكومه اليمن في ظل
عدم مرض الجيش الاسرائيلي والولايات
المتحده عنها اي حكومه في اليمن انت عندك
حكومه الحوثي وعندك اللي هي ما يسمى
بحكومه الشرعيه حكومه الشرعيه مرضي عنها
الى حد كبير ولكن نفوذها يعني مش موجود
على نصف اليمن اللي هي تحت سيطره الحوثي
بالنسبه للحوثي هي صمده بالفعل صمده
رغم انه زي ما انت بتقول كده اسرائيل مش
راضيه عليها دول الخليج مش راضيه عليها
ولكن هي كونت تحالفتها الخاصه بها
وعملت زي كوريا الشماليه عملت زي ايران
تعايشت مع العقوبات فلو توضح لي اي حكومه
يبقى الحديث يكون محدد
على فكره مره تانيه محمد هل يكون منظمه
بيكس
المسمار الاخير في ناس القطب الواحده انا
جاوبته بس طبعا ما فيش شك يعني ده هو انا
خلاص جاوبته اذا هم نجحوا في ان هم
يقلصوا دول الدولار بشكل كبير كما تتمنى
الصين وتتمنى روسيا وتتمنى دول اخرى وبدا
يحققوا نجاحات ما فيش شك ان دوت هيعمق من
تدهور النفوذ الامريكي في العالم
السلام عليكم برايك كيف استخرج امريكا من
سوريا هل بالقوه مثل لبنان 1983
وافغانستان في 2021
ولا ولا بالتفاوض
لا هي يعني
امريكا امريكا او اي قوه كبيره ما بتدخلش
بلد وتخرج منها كده طائعه مختاره يعني
لازم تكون في ضغوط عنيفه وتكون في خساير
كبيره وبالتالي يصبح بقائها
محل صداع لصانع القرار في الداخل يعني
يبقى في خسائر كبيره تبقى في تكلفه عاليه
تخرج لن تخرج
[ضحك]
نتمنى ما فيش حد يدمر حد يا علي يعني
نتمنى انه
انا طبعا بقول الكلام ده مش عاوز اكون ان
انا عايش فيه لا لا لاند يعني يعني انا ما
عنديش اي ثقه ابدا في انه
الكيان الاسرائيلي او الكيان الصهيوني هو
بطبعه عنده حاله خوف عنيفه والخوف ده
دايما بيخليه عدواني جدا
فهو النهارده مش طول ما ايران موجوده هو
مش مطمن قبلها لما كان العراق موجود هو مش
مطمن قبلها لما كان في حاله حرب مع مصر
ولسنوات ما كانش مطمن طول الوقت كده طول
الوقت ما ارتاحش ما بداش يركز على ايران
الا لما انهارت العراق ونهارت سوريا
وانهار لبنان وانكافات مصر على نفسها فهو
بيبحث عن اي دوله في دول الجوار وطول ما
دوله شامه نفسها هو بيشعر بالقلق
وبالتالي دايما يكون في صراعه
حضرتك
انا اسف مش عارف اقرا يا محمد حسن حضرتك
حاجه انت ما كملتش هل يمكن للصين ان تطيح
بامريكا
ايوه ممكن
معركه الصعود هي مش حاجه غريبه في التاريخ
يعني
الولايات المتحده هي القوه المهيمنه الصين
قوه صاعده ما المانع اذا اذا شفنا كده
بالمنطق العادي خالص اين كانت الصين في
الثمانينيات يعني من حوالي اربعين سنه
واين هي الان اقتصاد الصين في الثمانينيات
واواخر السبعينات كان اقتصاد صغير جدا
بيتكلم على حوالي تريليون دولار يعني
بنتكلم على اقتصاد يعادل دوله متوسطه في
اوروبا زي هولندا تقريبا يعني دايما كانوا
بيقارنوها بهولندا الصغيره جدا القلب
بنتكلم على ثاني اكبر اقتصاد بالقيمه
الاسميه اللي هو النوع من جي دي بي يعني
عدد الدولارات هنا وعدد الدولارات هنا
زي مثلا 20 تريليون دولار الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للصين مقابل حوالي 25 او 24
تريليون للناتج المحلي لامريكا لكن
القوه الشرعيه تجاوز الاقتصاد الصيني
الولايات المتحده
وعليه ايه المانع لو صارت الامور في نفس
مسارها ما المانع ان بعد عشره عشرين
ثلاثين سنه تكون هي القوه المتصدره يعني
الولايات المتحده ليست قدرا على العالم في
امبراطوريات كانت اكبر من الولايات
المتحده وانهارت يعني او ضعفت زي بريطانيا
اللي احنا شايفينها كلنا
وهو ده لب الصراع اللي موجود ان الولايات
المتحده عندها قناعه ايفر اما ان اجهز على
الصين الان كقوه عظمى او سوف
يتاخر الوقت
[موسيقى]
عبود بيقول ماذا حدث بالنووي الايراني هل
انتهت الازمه ده خالص الازمه لم تنتهي
ابدا ابدا ما زالت الازمه قضيه شائكه ما
زالت ايران
بتعمل يعني عاوز اقول بتتبع استراتيجيه
خطره جدا لكن بتلعبها بمهاره الاستراتيجيه
ديت هي مدركه ان كل ما يهم بالدول الكبيره
الغرب
الولايات المتحده كل ما يهم بلد زي
اسرائيل اللي كنا بنتكلم عليه هي الا تصل
الى السلاح النووي هي خلاص اصبحت لديها
المعرفه النوويه لتمكنها من صنع قنبله
نوويه ده ما عادش محل خلاف وامتلكت
الادوات وفاضل اتخاذ القرار ولمسات
الاخيره لانتاج القنبله النوويه هي عاوزه
حاجتين
انها تحصل على مقابل ضخم جدا في مقابل
التخلي عن اعطاء ضمانات بانها لن تطور
السلاح النوويه الان مقابل يعوضها عن كل
سنوات التضحيات في المواجهه مع الغرب من
سنه 79
ومين بتزود الضغط في المفاوضات عشان تحصل
على عائد اكبر بان هي كل ما بيعدي الوقت
كل ما بيصعب جدا تصفيه
قدرتها النوويه وبتقترب اكثر واكثر من
حلمها في امتلاك سلاح نووي
محمد هو محمد واحد ولا اكثر من محمد انا
شايف محمد هو تقريبا اللي مسيطر كله على
الاسئله مستقبل الصراع في ليبيا مش عارف
والله يا محمد لا اعلم بصراحه يعني انا
اجبت السؤال باكثر من صيغه بس كنوع من
الياس يعني انت عارف في دول يعني غرقت في
هذا المستنقع وهي مش حاجه غريبه يعني ده
حصل كتير بس هي
يعني انت لما تيجي تشوف الوضع في ليبيا
لما تشوف
يعني نفس الامثله خذ اليمن خد السودان
خذ لبنان خذ ايه ثاني خد تونس
الدول دي مش هتقدر تتجاوز عثرتها بس
بالنوايا والرغبه بين القوى المحليه انت
القوه المحليه ممكن تحسم الصراع لما يكون
في فرق كبير بين موازين القوى داخل اطراف
المحليه يعني مثلا في الحاله الليبيه لو
انه القوى اللي موجوده في الشرق
اقوى بكثير او بشكل واضح من القوى اللي في
الغرب كانت حسمت المسائل وما عادش في ازمه
لو انه مثلا في السودان ان في فريق قوي
جدا والجيش بيدعمه كانت المساله اتحسمت من
بدري جدا المشكله هنا ان عندك اطراف في كل
دوله قوى في بينها نوع من توازن القوه ما
فيش حد فيه قادر يحسم الصراع علشان السرعه
يتحسن في ليبيا ويتحسم فيه
السودان ويتحسم في اماكن اخرى كثيره لازم
المجتمع الدولي يكون راغب في حسم هذا
الصراع يعني القوه الكبيره ودول المنطقه
تكون مستفيده من التسويه انا بقول الكلام
ده من مثلا سنتين تلاته ورجعوا الحلقات لو
كان حضراتكم بتتابعوا دايما بقول ان مفيش
امل لهذه الدول ان تتحسم سرعتها الا لما
يحسب الصرع بين القوه الكبيره سواء
الدوليه او الاقليميه المثال اللي يدلل
على كده ايه بمجرد ما تحسنت العلاقات
ايران والسعوديه
انعكس ذلك ايجابا بشكل سريع على الملف
اليمني وبدء تتحرك بدات يبقى فيه بارقه
امل انه ممكن يحصل تحرك بدون ما يبقى في
اختلاف او توافق بين الدول الكبيره هيكون
صعب جدا ان الدول دي تخرج من عفريتها
السلام عليكم ممكن حلقه تشرح كيفيه حساب
نمو اي دوله وتشرح كيف هناك دول مثل لوكس
وسنغافوره نسبه التجاره الى الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي اكثر من 400 في الميه والموضوع
ده احنا تقريبا سجلناه بس ما ازعنهوش لكن
عبد الرحمن السويفي لكن الاجابه سريعه
وبعد كده ان شاء الله نخصص له حلقه مع
يعني في نعرف اقتصاد مع صديقي هاني جنينه
المساله ببساطه انه الدول اللي هي بتصدر
اكثر من الناتج بالنسبه للاول انت لازم
تعرف الاول الناتج الجي دي بيتحسب ازاي في
حلقه ادخل على نعرف اقتصاد هتلاقي الطرق
حساب
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ازاي بيتحسب احنا
بنتكلمين على الطرق التلاته
مثلا زي كوريا الجنوبيه الناتج المحلي لها
ازاي مثلا واحد منصه تريليون دولار
هل تصلح افكار مركز حاليا لا الاجابه لا
ما لا تصلح
ما رايك بالذي حدث على حدود فلسطين
والصواريخ التي خرجت من لبنان والسوريه
والله لغز كبير جدا هو طبعا لغز مش انه
حصل هو كان رد فعل يتكرر مع
الضغط الكبير اللي بيمارسوا المستوطنين
والمحتلين على الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وفي فصائل مسلحه بتكتسب شرعيتها من
المقاومه اذا كانت حتى فصائل لبنانيه
فلسطينيه ايا كانت جنسيتها فاذا لم ترد في
هذا الوقت فشرعياتها محل شك سواء كانت هذه
الفصائل بتحصل على شرعيتها او هي بالكامل
بتحصل على تمويلها وتسلحه من الداخل او من
الخارج هي موجوده علشان تعمل كده وبالتالي
لازم هتتحرك هذه الفصائل
لكن شويه مش واضح ان احنا مش عارفين مين
الفصائل دي على وجه التحديد
هل تحركت بموافقه من حزب الله ام لم يعني
تتحرك يعني علامات استفهام كثيره يعني
نقدر نفترض لكن لا استطيع ان نتاكد
هل ايران سوف تحارب اذرب ايجان العلاقه
بينهم متوتره يا علي بشكل كبير ولكن مش كل
توتر لازم يتحول الى حرب والا كانت وتسعين
دوله الموجودين في الامم المتحده واضف
عليهم
البلدان اللي تشبه دول زي تايوان يزيد
العدد العلميه 93 كان كلها حاربت بعضها
بعض
لماذا عانت سوريا لماذا عادت سوريا الى
حضن العرب حاليا بعد كل هذه الحروب التي
يذاقها الشعب السوري
لانه
ما فيش علاوات بتستمر الى الابد يا اخونا
الفارس انت واضح ان انت بتتكلم على ان انت
مليك موقف ضد الحكومه السوريه يعني بشار
الاسد هم في النهايه الدول بتدور على
مصالحها كل دول المنطقه ودول خارج المنطقه
لما هي خدت موقف ضد الرئيس بشار الاسد ما
كانش يعني طبعا جزء منه انه تم الضغط على
حكومات هذه الدول
بالعنف الشديد اللي واجهت به حكومه بشار
الاسد المظاهرات
انما كان في اعتبارات تانيه لان في دول
تانيه قامت فيها مظاهرات
والدول اللي ارادت الاطاحه ببشار بدعوى
انه يقمع شعبه دعمت حكومات اخرى مارست نفس
القمع يعني هي كل دوله بتدور على مصالحها
دلوقتي الدول العربيه ادركت بعد من 2011 ل
2013 بنتكلم على حوالي 12 سنه شايفين ان
المساله خساره الصافيه ليهم هم دفعوا
مليارات الدولارات
في محاوله للاطاحه ببشار الاسد هذه
المحاولات فشلت امام اولا هو ادارته
للازمه هو لوحده ادارته للازمه كانت اداره
جيده دعم ايران دعم روسيا كان اقوى بكثير
من المخططات من دول عربيه ودول غربيه
للاطاحه ببشار الاسد لان مصالح روسيا
وايران كانت كبيره في وجود بشار الاسد
الان الدول دي اللي بتقول له تعالى مره
تانيه لانه زي ما قلت في اول الحلقه هم
وجدوا ان الحسبه انهم خاسرين خساره كبيره
جدا سوريا تحولت الى قاعده
لمصالح ايرانيه
وايران على خلاف مع معظم مع كثير من الدول
العربيه
فوجدت انه فوجدوا ان انسحابهم من سوريا ده
افسح المجال لايران وعمق من نفوذها بشكل
اكبر الدول الغربيه وجدت انه
ترددها في الموقف السوري في القضيه
السوريه وتعاليها على بشار الاسد جعل من
اعطى لروسيا نفوذا ما كانت تحلم به ابدا
ما كانش اللي روسيا اي قواعد عسكريه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولا هذا الوجود الكبير
المؤثر المؤثر على مين مش بس في ان هي
عندها قواعد عسكريه اصبحت لاعبا اساسيا في
كثير من قضايا المنطقه تركيا ما تقدرش
تتحرك في سوريا او في اي منطقه الا لما
ترجع لروسيا دول الخليج لو عاوز اي مصلحه
لازم ترجع لروسيا عاوزين اي حاجه في مش
هيقدر اسرائيل دلوقتي كل حساباتها مبنيه
انها لازم تستاذن من روسيا حساباتها في
اوكرانيا مرتبطه بان هي اذا هي اعطت سلاح
لاوكرانيا الروس ممكن يعني
مكلفوهم غاليا ويمنعوا طائراتهم
ومقاتلاتهم من العبور فوق الاراضي السوريه
فاكتسبت نفوثا كبيره دلوقتي الدول دي
بتعيد النظر مره ثانيه في دول عندها مرونه
يعني تقدر تاخد القرار بسهوله زي بعض دول
الخليج مثلا او بعض الدول العربيه بصفه
عامه وفي دول غربيه عندها راي عام
وبرلمانات وعندها قوانين قالت ان الراجل
ده تورط فيه جرائم حرب ومش عارفين يغيروا
الدفه بسهوله
احنا صحيح ما تكلمناش حتى الان عن الوثائق
يعني احنا الاسئله كلها راحت في حته تانيه
ما هي التداعيات الاستراتيجيه لتسريب
الوثائق ده هو ده الموضوع الرئيسي للحلقه
ان انت بس الاسئله بدات اول تقريبا يعني
35 دقيقه الوثائق دي قصه كبيره
الوثائق لما يعني تقراها وتبعها والوسائل
الاعلام كل يوم بتترحم موضوع خطير جدا جدا
جدا
الخطير في الشكل وفي المضمون اولا من حيث
الشكل الوثائق دي جايه منين الوثائق ديت
قدمتها اجهزه مختلفه
للبنتاجون وزاره الدفاع جايه من السي اي
ايه والمخابرات اجهزه المخابرات الامريكيه
16 المختلفه وتسربت من مصدر رئيسي وهو
عشرات الوثائق المهمه الحدث الرئيسي فيها
اوكرانيا لكن في وثائق اخرى بتتناول شؤون
خارج او ملهاش علاقه مباشره باوكرانيا لكن
معظمها حوالين اوكرانيا
اول حاجه بنلاحظها في مساله الوثائق ديت
ان فعلا الولايات المتحده اذا صدقت هذه
الوثائق وضعت تحت كلمه اذا صدقت ديت عشرين
خط اذا صدقت هذه الوثائق وهي على الارجح
90% منها صادق فهي بتقول لنا ان الولايات
المتحده عندها قدرات استثنائيه في
الاستخبارات وهذا احد مصادر قوتها كدوله
عظمى احد مصادر قوتها واحد العلامات على
انها قوه عظمى هي عامله زي الاخطبوط او
كائن الهدره ده في الاساطير الاغريقيه
اللي هو عنده ثمان رؤوس امريكا عندها 193
راس في كل دوله عندها وسائل استخباراتيه
بعضها بشري بعضها بتخترق اجهزه
وبعضها التكنولوجيا المتقدمه بتستطيع ان
هي تتصنت على رؤساء الدول وهم في غرف
نومهم وفي مجالسهم الخاصه مع وزرائهم
والوثائق بتقول كده جايبه تفاصيل مش ممكن
حد يعرفها الا بطريقه من اتنين الطريقه
الاولانيه انه يا الرئيس وده مش ممكن او
المسؤول نفسه تم تجنيده اللي كان بيتكلم
مع هذا الرئيس او هذا المسؤول والطريقه
التانيه اللي هي الوسائل التكنولوجيا
المتقدمه اللي بتمكنهم من التجسس على
هؤلاء المسؤولين وهم لا يعلمون هل القصه
دي مفاجاه وجديده ابدا 2020 كان في فضيحه
كبيره معروفه شركه سويسريه كانت قوه يعني
عامله زي مثلا زي جوجل كده في في مجالها
في كسرش انجن ولا زي زي
فيسبوك ولا كل الحاجات الكبيره ديت في
مجالها ما هو مجالها هو تامين وسائل
التشفير والاتصالات بين الحكومات بين
الحكومه والحكومه وبين حكومه وحكومه
الشركه ديت على مدار عشرات السنوات كانت
بتتصدر سوق تامين الاتصالات
وحمايتك من التجسس تبين في 2020 في فضيحه
كبيره
ان هذه الشركه مملوكه يعني كل الحكومات
اللي كانت بتدفع اموال لهذه الشركه كانت
بتدفع اموال لشركه
بتنقل معلوماتهم الى السي اي فيحني ده
اولا عشان يعني ما اسرحش في الكلام كتير
اتنين ده من حيث الشكل وطبعا الشكل ده
هيترتب عليه المفروض انه كتير من الدول
هتعيد النظر في كل منظومتها والوسائل اللي
بيتم الاختراق بها بس مره تانيه واضح ان
الفرق في القوه كبير جدا في التكنولوجيا
والامكانيات اللي بتخلي امريكا برضو تعيد
مره ثانيه اختراقهم والتكسس عليهم اتنين
بقى المضمون الكلام اللي جاء في الوثائق
بيؤثر بشكل كبير على قضايا كثيره هنستوعبه
بالوقت يعني باختصار شديد لغايه ما تطرحه
مزيد من الاسئله كتير من تفاصيل حرب
اوكرانيا
ممكن يغير مسار الحرب كله لانه وثيقه
بتقول اولا الوثائق كلها بتقول ان الغرب
بيحارب روسيا على اراضي اوكرانيا قولا
واحدا كنا جميعا نرى ذلك نشعر به لكن اول
مره ان الاقي ارقام وتفاصيل توضح حجم
انخراط هائل من حلف شمال الاطلسي في هذه
الحرب انخراط هائل وبالتالي تبين لنا بعد
قراءه هذه المؤشرات ان روسيا لا تحارب
اوكرانيا ولكنها تحارب حلف شمال الاطلسي
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
كثير من التفاصيل اللي جت يمكن ان تغير
مسار الحرب الوثائق بتقول واحد انه
الامريكان اقترحوا على اوكرانيا انه تشن
هجومها في منتصف او في يعني تقريبا الشهر
المقبل اللي هو مايو 20 مايو مثلا بعد ان
تكون الارض جفت من الامطار وتستطيع دي
معلومه هل الروس كانوا محتاجين المعلومه
لا يعني اكدت صحيح ان ممكن يقدروا يعرفوا
ده لوحدهم لكن معلومه لكن اللي برضو كانت
روس ممكن يحتاجوه
وثيقه تقول كل تفاصيل وضع الجيش الروسي
الجيش الاوكراني عدد الذخائر اللي
بيحتاجوها في اليوم عدد الذخائر اللي نفذت
الاجهزه
منظومات الدفاع الجوي اللي تم اجهادها اذا
كان قصه 3 ولا اس ايه ولا اس ايه 11 على
ما اذكر وده كان موجود في المنطقه ديت
ونفذت زخائره واحد تاني يحسبه بدقه عندهم
مخزون من الذخائر عدده كذا سوف ينفذ حد في
اخر ابريل واجهزه اخر يعني منظومات اخرى
في اول مايو ومنظومات اخرى في اخر مايو
تفاصيل خطيره جدا جدا موجوده اكيد تساعد
الروس لو الروس وجدوا ان هذه المعلومات
حقيقه وليست فخا لما روسيا تعرف مثلا
الدول اللي هي فكرت او اللي هي ارسلت
اسلحه الى اوكرانيا سرا مهم جدا ومؤثر
عليهم ويعرف نوعيه الاسئله الاسلحه
محتاجينها
الوثائق مؤثره في المعلومات الاخرى اللي
هي جابتها عن الدول جايبه معلومات عن
كوريا الشماليه جايبه معلومات عن كوريا
الجنوبيه جايبه معلومات عن مصر جايبه
معلومات عن
الامارات جايبه معلومات عن كل حاجه
معلومات تفصيليه معظمها مرتبط ارتباط
مباشر باوكرانيا بس في معلومات اخرى ليست
مرتبطه بشكل مباشر باوكرانيا وبالتالي هي
ترتب على هذه الوثائق تغييرات كبيره زي ما
حصل مع تسريبات ادوار سنودل في 2013
يا ريت تركز معنا يا ماندو علشان البث
بيقطع ساعات
هو قطع النهارده يا عمر ده هو عمل حاجه
والله جديده خالص علينا بس يعني شرحها
ممكن يطلعنا بره الحلقه يعني النهارده
بتالي احسن ولا ايه
يعني لو البث النهارده لو ما كانش احسن
قولوا لنا
بفضل ماندو الحقيقه يعني
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله طابت اوقاتك بكل
خير معك عزيزي معك عزيز سؤالي هل تصريح
مكرونه يعني انه دق درعا بالولايات
المتحده وما هي تبعات هذا الشق هذا الشقاق
يعني في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اخونا عزيز تصريحات ماكرون خدت حيز كبير
جدا يمكن عشان التوقيت بس اللي تابع
تصريحات ماكرون اللي يتابع التصريحات كتير
من المسؤولين الفرنسيين تقليديا هيجدوا ان
هي صوت الاكثر يعني
سخونه في انتقاد الولايات المتحده او
الاكثر تعبيرا عن الرغبه في استقلال
الاتحاد الاوروبي واوروبا
عن السيطره الامريكيه من ايام طبعا شارلي
ديغول وهم بيتكلموا عن هذه القصه
مكرون ما قالش حاجه مختلفه عن اللي
بيقولوا منذ ان جاء للسلطه في 2017 مش
عاوزين اوروبا تبقى تابع للولايات المتحده
عاوزين اوروبا تكون هي القطب الثالث في
دوله متعدده الاقدام لا نريد عالما كان
الاول قصر على الولايات المتحده ثم اصبحت
عالما بيجمع بين الولايات المتحده والصين
نريد الاوروبا تكون هي القطب الثالث وانه
بما انها نقول القطب الثالث لازم هيكون
عندنا تناقضات مع الولايات المتحده
التناقضات ديت نديرها كحلفاء وليس يعني
تابعين للولايات المتحده لكن يمكن توقيت
الزياره يمكن
اصرار الولايات المتحده على التصعيد على
كل الجبهات بصراحه امريكا عاوزه تحرق تحرق
العالم كله في اندفاع شديد جدا لتدمير
روسيا في اندفاع شديد جدا لتركيع الصين
والتكلفه عاليه اكثر على الدول الاخرى من
على امريكا واللي بيقولوا ماكرون كلام جدا
بس يقدر ينفذه لانه اوروبا منقسمه
ما هو انت عندك في دول دول اوروبا الشرقيه
ديت بولندا بولندا دي قصه يعني دول زي دول
البلطيق دول قريبه من روسيا كتير زي الدول
اللي انضمت مؤخرا زي السويد وفنلندا دول
ديت عندها مقاس روسيا وعندها خوف شديد بس
في دول كانت واقفه على رجليها شويه
مثلا دوله زي المانيا امكانياتها
واقتصادها قدرت ان هي تقول انا اتعاون
وابقى متعاون جدا مع روسيا بحيث ان روسيا
لا تفكر ابدا في العدوان عليا والعدوان
عليا معناها حرب عالميه وفي دول اختارت
الحياد زي مثلا فنلندا والسويد قبل ما
يتغيروا وزي النمسا ما زالت وفي دول ضعيفه
جدا وجدت انه ما فيش حل غير ان انا اروح
انضم لحلف شمال الاطلسي الدول دي حتى الان
بتقول اتحاد اوروبي ايه وبتاع ايه انا
روسيا دلوقتي لو هاجمتني اتصل بمين اتصل
ببروكسل واقول لهم ان انا روسيا كل يوم
بتخترق المجال الجوي ليه وبتعمل عليا يعني
سايبر
ولا اتصل بالولايات المتحده هو ازمور مين
اللي له كده اللي عنده
ويعني ويحسب المسائل قناعتهم من الولايات
المتحده هي هي واشنطن هي الجهه التي يجب
ان يتصلوا بها وبالتالي ما عندهمش احترام
كبير قوي للاتحاد الاوروبي الا ككيان
اقتصادي وبالتالي كلام وفرنسا نفسها
بعد ما كانت قوه عظمى وبقت قوه متوسطه
بتنزف كل يوم يعني بتشوف وضعها في افريقيا
مش بس ان نفودها بيتراجع اجمع كده اكتب
كده ميكرون وبعدين المواجهات بينه وبين
رؤساء دول كتيره بيتعرض لاحراجات كبيره
لان هو بطبيعته راجل اكتر منه ما هو سياسي
يعني هو واضح ان هو كان راجل شاطر في
المدرسه
وقال كتير لكن بيدخل هو طريقته كده مش
عارف دي ثقافته ولا انا مش متخصص يعني في
التاريخ الفرنسي بس هم الفرنسيين يبدو انه
يعني هو حاجه عامه في فرنسا وحاجه خاصه
كمان بزياده اكتر في مكرونه يقول قعد مع
بوتين قاعد مع الرئيس المصري قعد مع رئيس
افريقي ينتقده وهو واقف فبالتالي بيجد
نفسه انه مضطر انه يرد ويرد رد يحرج مكرون
الى حد كبير فهل مكرون الكلام اللي بيقوله
ده يقدر ينفذه
هو كان واحد من اسباب خلافاته مع المانيا
انه كان يامل ان المانيا ما تجيبش اسلحه
من الولايات المتحده تاخد منه على اعتبار
ان بعد خروج بريطانيا هي اهم جيش في
اوروبا لكن المانيا
لا تثق في ان فرنسا تستطيع ان تحمي وحدها
هذا الاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي بدات
المانيا رغم انف فرنسا توثق علاقتها مع
الولايات المتحده وتحاول ان هي لا تغضب
الصين وتحاول الا تحرق كل جسرها مع روسيا
هل هو مخاط اسيا الجديده اسيا مش ده مش
مقارض الاساس الجديده ده مخدر العالم كله
العالم كله بيتشكل واللي مكرون قالوا فيه
كلمتين بلخص لنا الدنيا انه بعد ما كانت
العالم كله تحت سيطره الولايات المتحده
بنتكلم على قطبين هو بيقر بوجودهم الصين
مع امريكا وبيقول ان احنا كمان يجب ان
نكون قدا ثالثا لا ده ممكن يكون اكتر من
كده كمان وتكون في دول مؤثره ومهمه زي
مثلا تكتل على بعضه كده زي البريكس اللي
احنا كنا بنتكلم عليه
اسيا بقى دي قصه انا بسميها برميل البارود
اسيا جنوب شرق اسيا الاتنين مع بعض كده
سيبك من شمال اسيا ده كله روسيا وغرب اسيا
اللي هو الشرق الاوسط لكن جنوب وشرق اسيا
هذا برميل بارود وكل الصراعات وكل التقدم
وكل المستقبل فيه يعني
الامل في الاقتصاد العالمي فيه والخطر كله
بياتي منه دول كلها متحاربه مع بعضها
البعض اليابان
والصين سمع كل ضد كل الدول لكن كمان
اليابان مع الصين اليابان ضد كوريا
الجنوبيه كوريا الشماليه ضد كل الدول
المعادا الصين وروسيا
باكستان والهند الهند والصين كلها دول
قويه وعندها اسلحه تقليديه ضخمه وعندها
ترسينات نوويه ويعني
ما الذي سيجعل الصدام اقرب بين امريكا
ودول الشرق مثل الصين وروسيا المقصد انه
هل هناك حدث ممكن ان يجعل الحرب حتميه او
حدث لو حدث
بين امريكا ودول الشرق الاوسط
والدول الشرق اه مثل الصين وروسيا ما هو
الحرب لا ما فيش اكتر من كده يعني انت
بتتكلم على اوكرانيا اوكرانيا الاول كانت
بنتكلم على ان امريكا بتدعم
ان امريكا بتدعم اوكرانيا الان امريكا
تحارب روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه كل
يوم بيتاكد هذا الكلام باليقين والوثائق
جعلت من هذا يعني لا ليس محل شك فهما
بيحاربوا بعض السؤال بقى هل يمكن ان تتطور
لما هو اكثر اه يمكن ان تتطور لما هو اكثر
اذا وجدت روسيا نفسها يعني وانها يمكن ان
تخسر الحرب
يمكن طبعا غزو الصين لتايوان ده اهم حدث
يمكن ان يغير كل قواعد اللعبه ويمكن
للامريكان ان يجدوا انفسهم مضطرين الى
مواجهه عسكريه مع الصين
ايران ضرب ايران يمكن ان يؤدي ايضا الى
مواجهه بين الغرب وبين الصين وروسيا
مرحبا استاذ سيد اسم المصطفى لدي سؤال
لماذا ايران تدعم ارمينيا الدوله المسيحيه
ولا تدعم دوله اذربيجان مع العلم ان اظهر
ريجان شيعيه ايضا ما سبب الخلاف بين ايران
واضرب ايجان دي قصه طويله خالص لكن
الاجابه بسيطه جدا
اضرب اجانب كانت جزء من الامبراطوريه
الايرانيه ثم استقلت ثم ثم استولى علي
الاتحاد السوفيتي وسحباها من ايران وبعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي اصبحت اذربجان
دوله مستقله وارمينيا دوله مستقله بعيدا
عن ايران الان
في مشكله داخل اذربيجان بالنسبه لايران
مشكلتين اولا ان في طيار في اذربيجان
بيقول ان لينا اراضي ما في محافظه اسمها
اذربيجان محافظتين كمان اعتقد الغربيه
والشرقيه محافظتين ارجو ان تصححوا لي
موجود على الخريطه محافظتين
بيحملوا نفس الاسم يعني اضرب بيجان دي
منطقتين في ايران
غير دوله اذربيجان اذربيجان عندهم طيار
بيقول انه اذربيجان الكبرى يجب ان تضم
اقاليم من ايران هذا الامر طبعا سبب خلاف
رئيسي بين اذربيجان وبين ايران
الخلاف الثاني هو انه
اذربيجان منذ استقلالها في التسعينات
استعانت باسرائيل وقوت علاقتها بها واصبحت
اسرائيل بتستخدم اذربيجان احيانا للهجوم
على ايران والولايات المتحده احيانا
بتستخدم قواعدها في اذربيجان للهجوم على
ايران او التجسس عليها وده برضو مشكله
تانيه مش قادر افتكر المسئول الكبير اللي
اتكلم ولكن كانت كلم اظن وقال حجم العلاقه
بين الذره بايجان واسرائيل قوي في الظاهر
لكن هذه القوه ليست الا ذات طب
ليست الا راس جبل الجليد في اشاره الى ان
الحجم التعامل بين الضربيجان واسرائيل ضخم
جدا هذا ايضا مشكله اخرى تالق تؤرق ايران
فيما انه في المساله ملهاش علاقه بالبعد
الدين يكونك مسلم شيعي على عيني وراسي لكن
هو بصالحه موجوده يعني الخلافات السياسيه
اقوى من الروابط المذهبيه يعني
السلام عليكم ممكن حلقه تشرح لنا فيها
حساب نمو اي دوله ده احنا اجبناها ده
انا مش عارف اذا كنت جاوبت ولا لا بس اظن
على في كل الاحوال محمد طريقه حساب الجي
دي بي اظن ان انا جاوبته في الحلقه ديت
ارجع للحلقه موجوده على اقتصاد نعرف
موجوده وليه صادرات دوله بتزيد عن ناتجها
المحل المساله بسيطه خالص هي مثلا في
طريقه الحساب يعني ان هي
بتسرف في الاستيراد ثم اعاده التصدير مره
اخرى فبتبقى الواردات اللي مش محسوبه من
الجي دي بي حجمها كبير جدا وهتبقى في حلقه
ان شاء الله نوضح فيها ده بشكل يعني
هتلاقي مثلا في الدول اللي هي زي سنغافوره
هتلاقيها دوله زي ممكن اظن الامارات
هتلاقيها دول
بتعتمد على اعاده التصدير بشكل كبير يعني
محمد
بيقول شكرا على مجهودك ممكن تتكلم على
التسريبات الامريكيه وعن رايك
فيها من المستفيد والمتضرر ومن تتوقع ممكن
تسرب لا ده هي دي ما فيش توقعات الحقيقه
بس هو يعني لما تيجي تشوف كده كل
الاحتمالات موجوده دلوقتي موقف الروس
بيعبر تقريبا عن راي
يعني تقريبا كلنا ليه راي الروس لانه هم
بس اللي اتكلموا يعني يعني الروس قالوا
ايه قالوا احنا قلقانين ان الكون الوثائق
دي
فخم من امريكا الفخ ده يعني ايه يعني تكون
90% من الوثائق ديت سليمه
والامريكان سربوها علشان يدسولنا فيها
عشره في المئه
توماس ليداس عشان يضللون
بغض النظر عن راي الروس انت عندك الوثائق
هذا الدول كثيره او مس الدول كثيره عندك
كل السيناريوهات واردها السيناريو
الاولاني انه دوله عملتها كينج هم اول
دوله اتهموها روسيا بس بس الحقيقه روسيا
تعتبر مدروره شويه من الوثائق يعني او على
الاقل
خلينا نقول ده احتمال او الاحتمال الثاني
زي ما حصل مع ادوارد سنودن ان شخص داخل
الولايات المتحده سرب الوثائق لشخص يسرب
الوثائق
عنده دوافع كثيره ممكن تكون دوافع المال
ممكن تكون الخلافات الضخمه جدا داخل
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده منقسمه
على نفسها خصوصا بانه مع اقتراب 202
انتخابات الانقسام على اشده ممكن في ناس
يعني منزعجه يعني في ناس بتعمل ده لانه
حاسه مش راضيه على سياسه الولايات المتحده
في كل الاحوال اللي يهمنا ده هيبان في
التحقيقات لكن اللي يهمنا انه التحقيقات
دي ان الوثائق دي لازم تعامل بحذر شديد
والاكيد اكتر انه جزء منها يبدو انه صادق
100% في تفاصيل يصعب تزويرها يعني لكن هل
كل الوثائق دقيقه ده بقى مساله يعني عاوزه
جهد كبير وعاوزه تحقيق من الدول وكل واحد
يشوف الوثائق اللي يخصه ويشوف الكلام اللي
حصل ده واللي
الناتج عن تجسس الولايات المتحده عليك كان
دقيق قد ايه
اسرائيل ستضرب ايران والصين ستدخل تايوان
وحرب عالميه اريد رايك ما رايك فيما سيقع
طب ما انت قلت كل الكلام يا اخونا
المدام اسرائيل ستضرب ايران والصين سوف
تدخل طهران ما تبعا لازم تبقى حرب عالميه
طبعا
ما هي فرص نجاح دول الخليج في تحويل
نظامها يعني مش عاوز تجاوز سؤالك ولا حاجه
بس يعني اذا حدث اللي انت بتقول عليه ده
فرص انه تكون في يعني
انفجار ضخم في العالم وارد
بس يعني عاوز اذكرك برضو ان التاريخ
بيعلمنا ان في احداث كنا نتوقع ان هي تكون
نهايه العالم وحادثه وتجاوزها العالم يعني
ما كانش حد يتخيل انه روسيا
قبل فبراير من 2022 هتخش اوكرانيا وتدخل
في صراع مع حلف شمال الاطلسي
ويبقى ويتحول الصراع بعد 14 شهر الى صراع
العالم بيتعايش معه يعني
صحيح انه لسه الصراع مفتوح لكن برضو وارد
انه يتم التاقلم معه ويصل الى حل يتم
تقسيم اوكرانيا
ويعني هي تعيشوا معي مش لازم ينهار العالم
ويستخدموا السلاح النووي يعني
القسم قد تتكرر في تايوان
ما هي فرص نجاح دول الخليج في تحويل
نظامها الاقتصادي من الاعتماد الكامل على
النفط الى الاقتصاد المفتوح والله صعب جدا
يعني هو ده محمد عطوان ما هي فرص نجاح دول
الخليج يعني يعني السؤال نتمنى هم يتمنوا
هل هم نجحوا في الاربعين سنه اللي بداوا
يحطوا فيها خطط عشرين وتلاتين سنه لا لم
ينجحوا كما كانوا يامنوا حققوا نجاحات
يعني اقل بكتير من اللي كانوا بيخططوا له
هل هم جديين بعض الدول جاده في المساله
ديت انما هي مساله صعبه لكن واضح ان في
مؤشرات الان على نجاحها
لماذا ماكرون يسر على تعديل تعديل ده
اخونا وولف
لماذا ميكروني السره على تعديل نظام
التقاعد رغم تصاعد الاحتجاجات انا
المعلومه اللي عندي هي القصه ان تضاعف
الاقتصاد الفرنسي انت عاوز تعمل نظام
تقاعد يدي للناس المعاشات عند 62 وهو
بيقول انه انا بقى عندي مشكله نتيجه
رفاهيه الشعب الفرنسي ناس بتعيش كتير قوي
بيعيشوا حوالي 25 سنه بعد ما بيطلعوا معاش
يعني متوسط الاعمار وصل لفوق ال 85 انا
عشان الدوله الفرنسيه تدي لناس رعايه مرتب
وتدي لهم تامين صحي لمده 25 سنه وهو لا
ينتج مساله اكبر من قدرات
الصندوق او الدوله الفرنسيه التمويل عندنا
عجز لن نستطيع الاستمرار في ذلك الحل ان
انا اخفف من العجز ده انه الشخص ده يستمر
في الانتاج لعامين اضافيين يبقى نحاول
شويه
ان احنا نخفف من هذا الجاب الكبير او هذا
الخلل وزي ما قلت لكم اللي بيزود من هذه
الفجوه انه كتير من الشباب الفرنسي لا
يريد الانجاب فبالتالي عدد الشباب الصغير
اللي بيدخل سوق العمل اقل عشان الناس
تطلعوا معيش لازم غيرهم يدخل لسوق العمل
يعمل وينتج وهو بيعمل بينتج بيطلع جزء من
معاشه للادخار علشان ياخد فيبقى ياخده من
الفلوس ديت ويده للمتقاعدين لا من يدخل
لسوق العمل من الشباب اقل مقارنه بعدد
العجائز اللي بيخرجوا او المتقاعدين كمان
الدول ديت لاسباب كثيره بقت حتى ضوابط
كتير على الهجره الشرعيه فكمان مش قادره
تستعين بشباب من الدول الافريقيه
والاسيويه يعوض نقص الانجاب ومعدلات
الانجاب عند الفرنسيين وغيرهم
هذا ما اعلمه
توقعاتك فلورينا
توقعاتكم استاذي عن مستقبل ونتائج
المحابسه المحادثات اليمنيه الجاريه الان
والله الاعمال الهوبس
الكبيره جدا الكل ارهق
والكل راغب في انه
يعني يضع نهايه لهذه الماساه بس انا عندي
مجموعه من الاسئله مش عارف يعني هيقولوا
لها حل ازاي تعال ناخد الصوره السيناري
الايجابي تم وقف عمله هدنه طويله او عملوا
اتفاق سلام وتبادلوا الاسرى وبدات طيران
يجي في صنعاء وفي عدن وفي اسئله كتيره
اللي هيحصل كله بمعنى اصح بمعنى اصح انه
هيبقى في اتفاق ما بين الحوثيين ده اللي
انا شايفه دلوقتي ما بين الحوثيين وما بين
دول الخليج او الدول الدول الخارجيه انه
نتعايش لا تهاجمون لا تضربون بالصواريخ لا
تعرقلوا الملاحه البحريه ولا الجويه طبعا
نتخلص من
السفينه اللي عامله قلق بايديت اللي هي
خزان صافر يعني نهدي المسائل وبالتالي
يبقى الاجواء تهدا انما السؤال اللي هو
صعب جدا طيب اصبحت السعوديه الان
والامارات ودول الخليج المختلفه مش في
حاله حرب ومش مستنزفه ومش مهدده باتفاق
لكن السؤال اللي محدش بيجاوب عليه
والملاحه تسير بشكل جيد السؤال اللي محدش
لسه بيجاوب عليه هل سوف يظل الحوثيين
يسيطرون على نصف اليمن
وهل سوف تظل القوى الاخرى كلها موجوده في
ما يسمى بجنوب اليمن هو المفروض يسموه شرق
غرب بس يعني دي قصه طويله بيسموه شمال
وجنوب جنوب اليمن هل الجنوب هينفصل هل
الحوثيين مستعدين للتفاوض مع هذه القوه ان
هم يتفاوضوا مع السعوديين يتفاوضوا مع
السعوديين والاماراتيين على ايه يعني
دعني اعمل دعني امر سيبني في اليمن اعطيني
رواتبي ارفع الحصار عني وانا اكف اذاعي
عنك مفهوم هذا ما يتمناه السعوديين هذا ما
يتمناه دول كثيره لكن فيما يتعلق بالشان
الاماراتي ده بشان اليمني ده معناها انه
المؤشرات بتقول ان الحوثيين اصبحوا فاكتور
لايف يعني اصبحنا قدام ما يشبه ايران
جديده موجوده ايضا في جنوب السعوديه يعني
ما فيش اي مؤشرات على انهم بيقولوا ان هم
هيمشوا
والقوه اللي موجوده دي في الجنوب عندها
جزء منها عنده مشروع يستقر في الجنوب فكره
ان هم يتصالحوا فكره ان هم
يتفاوضوا فكره ان الديطانت اللي انا شايفه
ده عمليه الانفراجه تنسحب على الشق اليمني
اليمني مش مطروحه مش مطروحه بشكل واضح
وباي شروط
السؤال التاني اذا هم لجاوا الى هذا
السيناريو واصبحت ما فيش مشكله ما بين
القوى اليمنيه او بين الحوثيين والدول
الخارجيه هل مش ممكن الخلافات اليمنيه
اليمنيه تفجر الموقف مره اخرى
وتعود الاوضاع برضو تنزاح الى الخارج
فيعني اسئله كثيره
احسن سيد قبيل في العالم ربنا يخليك يا
صديقي الله يحفظك عبده
السلام عليكم استاذ لماذا حضرتك تتجاهل
منصه تويتر فيها ميزه المساحات واتمنى من
حضرتك تفتح مساحات على تويتر لكان التفاعل
مع حضرتك بشكل مباشر نفسي اعرف يا حمزه
انا طرحت السؤال ده انا ممكن استفيد من
تويتر ازاي انا مش قادر اعرف الناس
بتستفيد من تويتر زي انا عارف ان السؤال
يبدو ساذج بس انا حقيقي مش عارف اللي انا
بشوفه ان في ناس بيطرحوا اراء مختصره
فمش عارف بيعملوا ايه مش عارف ازاي انه حد
عنده يعني مضمون او محتوى من النوع اللي
انا بقوله اللي هو بيكون شويه كبير وبتعمل
في شكل فيديو ازاي ينقل الى تويتر انا مش
عارف
ولما سالت ناس كتير يقول لي بديهي جدا بس
لما يكلمني برضو انا مش فاهم ممكن احول
هذا المحتوى لتويتر اذا كنت تعرف يا ريت
تقول لي
متى يبدا الاعبار في سوريا هل بعد التقارب
الذي يحدث في منطقه والله ده سؤال مهم زي
السؤال اللي كنا بنقوله في اليمن سوريا
هتقابلها مشكله قدام شويه انه نفترض
دلوقتي مش نفترض المؤشرات كلها بتقول ان
السرعه عائده انا هتشارك في مؤتمر القمه
العربيه في مايو القادم في الرياض وفي هذا
المؤتمر سوف تعلن عن عوده سوريا
ويتبادلوا السفارات في كل مكان السفاره في
السعوديه والسفاره يا فاضل مين يا فاضل
للسعوديه وفاضل قطر
ويرفعوا مستوى التمثيل اكثر مع مصر يعني
طيب السؤال بقى الدول دي يعني الدول دي
عاوزه حاجات واضحه من سوريا واحد
مش عاوزين تجار تركب تجون دي تاني يا سيد
بشار الاسد عاوزين نضع ضوابط عليها اثنين
احنا محتاجين انك تفتح يعني تساعدنا في
التهدئه في سوريا بانك تفتح قنوات الاتصال
مع المعارضه على الاقل شريحه منهم ثلاثه
انك تخفف شويه من يعني اعتمادك الكبير جدا
على ايران هفترض ان هم يتوصلوا الى حلول
وسط في كل المطالب اللي بيقولوا عليها دي
سوري عاوزه ايه سوري عاوزه مساعدات
اقتصاديه عاجله وعاجله جدا عاوزاها امبارح
مش النهارده طب الدول العربيه ديت عشان
تحاول تضخ استثمارات هتصطدم بالعقوبات
الغربيه مش الامريكيه بس هل الدول دي كل
الشركه هتشارك الامريكان سوف يضعوا عليها
قائمه اكس لن تشارك في الولايات المتحده
ولن تشارك في الخارج سوف توضع عليها
عقوبات
فاذا لم ينجح تنجح الدول العربيه في الضغط
على الولايات المتحده واوروبا في تحييد
هذه العقوبات هتكون في صعوبات كبيره جدا
او بقى الدول العربيه كلها هتتحول الى
الكتله الشرقيه بالكامل وهيتجاهله
للولايات المتحده وده يبقى تطور خطير جدا
تحياتي لك يا استاذي الفاضل اقترح سلسله
عن الاتفاقات الدوليه المهمه ذات التاثير
الكبير والله يا علي اقتراح جميل جدا
نتمنى ربنا يمكنا ان شاء الله يعني زي ما
دايما بقول النفس راغبه ضعيف هل سينفصل
اليمن اليمن انفصل يا اخونا شاعر انفصل
بالفعل بقى على ارض الواقع عندك يا من
جنوبي ويا من شمالي واللي يعرف ليه بيسموه
اليمن الجنوبي جنوبي مع انه ممكن يسموه
اليمين الشرقي
اليمن الشمالي شمالي ليه ده يعني ما هو
الشمالي ده هو يعني يعني شرق وغرب
هل الجويش الروسي فاشل ليه فاشل بقى عليه
ده الدعايه الغربيه اللي بتسميه فاشل طب
انا هقول لك على حاجه يا علي هو الجيش
الروسي فاشل ليه الجيش الروسي
طبعا هو متعثر 14 شهر يعني عنده خسائر
كبيره جدا لكن عاوز اقول لك ان الجيش
الروسي عنده 14 بقى له 14 شهر في اوكرانيا
بيسيطر على الاقل عشرين في الميه من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ويقوم بتقدم مستمر في الشهور الاخيره رغم
انه بيحارب حلف شمال الاطلسي كما تقول
الوثائق كلها
الولايات المتحده والغرب كله كان في
افغانستان واحتاج 20 سنه ثم خرج منها
صاغرا وبنظر الطائرات يبقى ايه اللي اختلف
يعني اذا كان فكره عدم قدرته على الحسم في
اوكرانيا معناه انه جيش فاشل يبقى
الولايات المتحده جيش فاشل لانه فشل بعد
عشرين سنه في في افغانستان وفاشل بعد غزوه
لاوكرانيا للعراق من سنه 2003 اللي غزاها
بعد نظام عقوبات استمرت 13 سنه من سنه 90
لسنه 2003 ويبقى نظام فاشل انه خرج مهزوم
من الصومال وهيبقى فاشل لانه لم يحزن
ويبقى فاشل طبعا لانه قضى سنوات طويله في
فيتنام ثم خرج
دون ان نحقق اهدافه بشكل كبير يعني
السوشيال ميديا
معك انشاء معك ان شاء الله عمر النهارده
ده مش مقطع مش هيقطع خالص
اه ماشي تمام اه انت اللي رد عليه يعني
طيب تمام زي الفل
اسرائيل ستضرب ايران والصين
عبد الرحمن السويفي السلام عليكم ممكن
حلقه عبد الرحمن نبغى حلقه عن اضرب ايجان
والله نعمل حلقه عن اقرب بس يعني عشان ما
تقوليش انت قلت وعدت هنا اذا لا قدر الله
تصاعدت الاحداث عن اذربيجان والله اللي
انا بقوله لكم ده انا صادق فيه يعني انا
مثلا جهزت نفس الحلقه دي عن اضربيجان اجهز
الحلقه يحصل توتر هنتكلم عن القطر بعد 48
ساعه الاحداث ويلقى حدث تاني فاتجاوزها
واروح لحلقه تانيه انما انا احب اتكلم عن
اذرع يعني ملف في حاجات انتريجينج هو
وارمينيا والعلاقات ده الحاجه اللي انا
شخصيا بحبها يعني نوعيه هذه القضايا
صديق قديم هانز زمر بس يا ريت تقول لنا
اسمك الحقيقي ما هي التغيرات في سياسه
فرنسا الخارجيه بعد زياره ماكرون للصين
برايك هل باستطاعه امريكا باقناع دول
العشرين بتكرار سيناير العقوبات
الاقتصاديه على روسيا اذا قررت الصين بضم
تايوان عسكريه لا احنا بنتكلم على على
سؤالين التغيرات في سياسه فرنسا الخارجيه
هنا ما فيش تغير في سياسه فرنسا الخارجيه
هي فرنسا منذ فتره وهي بتطالب الاوروبيين
ان يكونوا اكثر اعتمادا على انفسهم بتقول
كتير تقدر حتى الان ما قدرتش لازم تقنع
المانيا لازم تقنع عدد من الدول وتحديدا
المانيا حتى الان لم تنجح
اما السؤال التاني
تقنع الدول العشرين بفرض عقوبات
فرض عقوبات على الصين يعني
[موسيقى]
هي في مجموعه العشرين نجحت في ايه ده
مجموعه العشرين مقدرش يطلعه
يعني بيان حاسب بحاجه عمليه مفتوحه قعدوا
سنتين ما يطلعوش بياناته وبعدين في البيان
الاخير طلعوا بيان كده في اتفاض ما بيقولش
اي حاجه يعني
وعموما اذا انت بتقول اذا ضمه الصين
تايوان العالم كله هيبقى متغير فيعني
المساله مش هتقف على مجموعه العشرين اللي
هي ممكن تنهار كلها لانه في الحاله ديت
يبقى عندك الصين وروسيا اللي هم دولتين
مؤثرتين ومعاهم دول من دول هم يعني على
العلاقه وثيقه بالسين وروسيا
هيكون العالم انقسم تماما بقى على محاور
مختلفه يعني تتجاوز فكره ان الدول الكبيره
يلتقوا في فورم واحد
ما مصلحه مصلحه
طلب امريكا من مصر مواجهه روسيا في
افريقيا
ابو شيخه النهاري ما اعرفش ما صحت ومن قال
كده انا ما اعرفش مساحه طلب امريكا من مصر
اه طلب امريكا من مصر مواجهه روسيا في
افريقيا لا معرفش برضو انا قراتها العكس
ما اعرفش انه لكن مش هندهش ان ده يحدث
لانه امريكا بتطلب من كل الدول
الحليفه لها الصديقه لها ومصر على الورق
دوله صديقه لامريكا وهي على علاقه وثيقه
بها منذ اتفاقيه السلام مع اسرائيل في سنه
وبعد المبادره سنه 77 اللي هي زياره
الرئيس السادات لاسرائيل منذ سنه 80 مصر
بتحصل على مساعدات انوالي تم تخفيضها
مساعدات اقتصاديه تم تخفيضها بشكل كبير
ومساعدات عسكريه ما زالت في حدود واحد من
عشره مليار دولار الرقم الصغير لكن الاهم
من الرقم معناها انه كميه من الولايات
المتحده ان انت دوله عليه فهو صديقك وفي
مقابل هذه المساعدات مصر بتدي امتيازات
كبيره للولايات المتحده
انما فمش غريبه ان الولايات المتحده تطلب
من مصر ان هي تقف معها في تصورها للقضيه
ديت لكن هي طلبت ده من مصر وطلبتهم من كل
دول العالم عدد الدول الاستجاب ليس كبيرا
لان الدول دي زي ما قلت لحضراتكم بدا يبقى
عندها التصور مختلف واحد ان هم شايفين ان
الولايات المتحده لا يمكن الوثوق فيها هي
بتطلب طلبات احيانا يمكن ان تورط دوله ثم
لا تنقذها والمثال الشهير اللي هو الدول
الكبيره في اوروبا
يعني افرضوا عقوبات على الغاز الروسي
فردنا عقوبات على الغاز الروسي طيب عاوزين
بدائل اشتروا مني الغاز نبيعه لكم باربع
وخمس اضعاف
امريكا عملت
الصامت بتاع الدول الافريقيه من عده شهور
من حوالي 3 شهور او حاجه زي كده وقالت انا
هتبرع وهذا عام افريقيا بخمسين مليار
دولار دول افريقيا 54 دوله وجدت امريكا
لما عاوزه ترجع للقاره بتتكلم على خمسين
مليار دولار يعني لو ان الرقم ده هيتوزع
تقريبا بالتساوي يعني كل دوله تاخد اقل من
مليار دولار
رقم مالوش قيمه ده اذا افرك عن هذا الرقم
فحقيقي وجودها محدود في افريقيا دول سنترا
الايجا دول الاسيا الوسطى كل الاستانس دي
التركمانستان وكازاخستان والى اخره امريكا
حاولت ان هي تقلل النفود الروسي والصيني
راح هناك وزير بلنكن في مارس اللي فات
ومعاه حزمه مساعدات للخمس دول اللي هناك
خمسه مليون دولار وكانت اول من سنه على
الاقل اللي مسؤول امريكي كبير في مقابل
مشروع الحرير الصيني اللي بمليارات
الدولارات في اسيا الوسطى وفي مقابل حضور
روسي ضخم جدا الرئيس الروسي مش وزير
خارجيته خمس مرات خلال السنه اللي فاتت
وعمل اجتماعات بالفيديو حوالي 45 مره في
50 لقاء لبوتين مع زعماء هذه الدول
او عبر فيديو في مقابل لقاء يعني على
مستوى وزير خارجيه يعني هناك لهذه الدول
فيعني لا
التراجع الامريكي مش اوهام ولا حاجه واضح
على الارض يعني
امريكا بتفكرنا بالدوله الكبيره اللي هي
لسه دوله كبيره بس حقيقي ما عدتش قادره
على ان هي تدير العالم كله منفردا كما
اعتادت ان تفعل في التسعينات والسنوات
اللي سبقتها
هل سيتحسن السلام عليكم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله انا مش عارف انا
عديت حاجه ولا مرحبا سيد جبيل ما قسم ما
قصه قصف تركيا لمطار السليمانيه مش عارف
غير اللي اذيع اللي هم كانوا بيستهدفوا
قائد قوات قصد وهم بيستهدفوا الكرد
الجماعات الكرديه المسلحه في كل مكان زي
ما قالت لي احدى الشخصيات السياسيه
الكرديه يعني انه هم بيقولوا لهم لو بنى
الكرد خيمه في جنوب افريقيا لضربناها
ما اعتقدش ان لها بعد اكثر من ذلك يعني
السيد ممكن تتكلم عن تصريحات
احنا اجابنا السؤال دوت السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
عزيزنا السؤال علي هل سيتحسن التضخم
العالمي
والله التضخم العالمي
هو التضخم في العالم كله ارتفع مش غريبه
انه يرتفع في الاسواق الناشئه اللي هي
اسواقها هشه وبتعتمد على الاستيراد بشكل
كبير الدول الناشئه الاول بتواجه في
السنتين ثلاثه الاخريتين موقف صعب جدا هذه
الدول الدول الناشئه يعني الاسواق الدول
الناميه اللي هي دول الشرق الاوسط منها
باستثناء الدول الغنيه
اللي عندها غاز وبترول الدول دي بتتعصر
بتتعصر ليه دول ديت بتعتمد على احتياجاتها
الاساسيه كلها استيراد ووجدت مشكلتين
المشكله الاولانيه
انه كل السلعه الاساسيه تضاعف ثمنها بعد
ازمه كورونا والخلل في سلاسل الامداد اللي
اتكلمنا عليه كتير ثم المشاكل البيئيه ثم
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه فالحاجه اللي
كانوا بيجيبوها بدولار باقي يجيبوها
بتلاته واربعه وخمسه دولار ده واحد
بيسعوا انه يجيبوها وبعدين وجدوا علشان
يجيبوها لازم يعتمدوا على القروض بيمولوا
قرض بقرض وجدوا ان هم علشان يقترضوا
الحاجه اللي كانت بدولار هيجيبوها بخمسه
وعشان ياخدوا قرض اللي كانوا بياخدوه
بواحد في الميه ثلاثه في الميه اربعه في
الميه هياخدوه بعشره و12% وفي صعوبه في
الاقتراض فمن الناحيتين عندهم صعوبات
بالغه ودول كتيره زي ما بقول لكم بتعصر
عصرا
وكتير من الدول دي قد يواجه متاعب
اجتماعيه واضطرابات داخليه كبيره وافتكروا
ان كان في حلقه في اول الازمه بعنوان هل
تؤدي حرب اوكرانيا الى ربيع عربي جديد
استاذنكم ارجعوا اليها من حوالي سنه
في الجزء تاني من سوق حضرتك لكن التدخل في
الدول الكبيره بقى عنيد جدا يعني التضخم
معدي الخمسه والسته والسبعه في الميه في
اوروبا طبعا بيختلف من دوله للثانيه
والولايات المتحده عالي جدا هم الفائده
وصلت لمستويات قياسيه ازالات الفائده اكثر
من كده معناها انه هيكون في ضحايا كتير
بنجبه انهار شركات بتنهار
المتوقع انه يتحسن يعني مش معقول هيفضل
كده كتير لكن انت يتحسن وباي ثمن ويوصلوا
بالفايده لغايه فين عشان التضخم يتحسن دي
مساله محتاجين نراقبها ونراها
احمد السلام عليكم ورحمه الله استاذنا
المحترم من كم يوم ايمانويل ماكرون صرح في
معناه ان انه على اوروبا عدم والاجابه مش
السؤال مش كامل ازاي كل الدول الناتو غير
النيتو بتدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا وماديا وكل
حاجه وفي العلن وحلال ولما او الصين تدعم
روسيا الدنيا تقوم عليهم وداعمي
وداعمين للارهاب وتهديدات امريكا لهم اما
طبعا
ما هو ده جزء من هو ما فيش اسلوب يعني
المساله مش مساله مبدا هو القوه الغالبه
القوه الكبيره اللي بتسيطر على النصيب
الاكبر من مقدرات العالم اهي الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وهم بيعملوا معايير الصح
والصواب وفقا لهم فالكلام ده لما كنا
بنقوله احنا هنا في المنطقه يقول لنا انتم
مهووسين بان انتم
يعني ضد اليهود ضد اسرائيل رغم ان العمليه
رغم ان العالم العربي كله قبل خلاص على
الاقل من سنوات باسرائيل وحدود
حددت الامم المتحده لكن
هم طالبين هم بيدعموا اسرائيل حتى فيما لا
يمكن ان يقبله اي منطق وعاوزين يعتبروا ده
هو المنطق وهو العقل
نفس القصه التي تتكرر رئان الدول الاخرى
بتشعر بها
ليه الصين ليه تدخل الصين
مثلا دول اخرى لدعم
روسيا في اوكرانيا يبقى مخالف وهم يدعموا
اوكرانيا مش مخالف لانه هم بيقولوا اللي
هيتدخل انا كامريكا هفرد عليه عقوبات وانا
اكبر سوق في العالم فبغض النظر على انه
الامم المتحده تقول او القوانين الدوليه
تقول انا امريكا ربع اقتصاد العالم ومعايا
حوالي اربعين دوله يعني بنكون يعني الجزء
الاكبر من الاقتصاد العالمي كلنا هنفرض
عليه عقوبات فخلاص هذه القوه يعني بالبروت
الفورس بالقوه الغاشمه احنا هنفرض منطقنا
وهنفرد قوانيننا وهو ده اللي بيخلي دول
كتيره تبدا تتمرد على هذا
الموقف المتوحش
محمد حسن حضرتك متحمل على زلينسكي في انه
سبب الحرب الحرب بدات من قبل روسيا
بانتهاكها القانون الدولي واخذى ارض دوله
اخرى في القرن ومع ذلك
صبره اوكرانيا وحاولت الحل دبلوماسيا ولكن
روسيا هي الشيطان في الحقيقه
نظري يا محمد انا مش ما بقولش انه
يعني ما انت ممكن تصور الوضع كالاتي لنسكي
بطل قومي بيدافع عن حقوق شعبه ما هو ده
صحيح ولكن انا اللي انا بقوله ان احنا لا
نعيش في عالم كده بلا
يعني مش في عالم
مش عارف اقول ايه يعني احنا مش بنتكلم في
الكتب مش في نظريات مطلقه كده
انت بتتكلم على دوله صغيره تجاور عملاقا
كبيرا
بقطع النظر عن تصورات روسيا وبقطع النظر
عن يعني ادعاءاتها التاريخيه وعن شعورها
بالخطر انا كزعيم دوله قدام الموقف التالي
اذا انا استفزيت هذا العملاق في المطالبه
بحقي روسيا اذا انا حاولت اوصل معايا لحل
وسط هتاخد جزء من حقوقي لكن هفضل اوكرانيا
موجوده اذا انا تحديتها واصريت على
استفزازها بالانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
والانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي مش هيكون
في اوكرانيا كلها موقف صعب على اي شخص انا
ما اخذه على زلينسكي او غيره انه
ما اخترعش العجله يعني الدول كتيره ودول
في المنطقه هنا كتيره وفي افريقيا وفي
اسيا وفي امريكا اللاتينيه كل حته وفي
امريكا الشماليه نفسها يعني المكسيك وكندا
وكذا بيشوف نفسه موقف بيلاقي انه بيتعامل
مع
ديناصور كبير جنبه الذكاء في انك تدير هذا
العلاقه مع هذا الديناصور بحيث الا تسمح
له ان ينهسك هو النهارده دفع دفعا يعني
الروس كان عندهم مطالب كان في حلول وسط
على الاقل من وجهه نظري مش من وجهه نظري
على الاقل من وجهه نظر اوكران من وجهه نظر
امريكان من وجهه نظر اوروبيين شايفين ان
كان في حلول مقبوله بدليل ان هي ما فكرتش
في دخول اوكرانيا الا 2014 فكان ممكن
تخشيها في 2013 و2012 و2010 و2008 فحصل
عمليه استفزاز شديده جدا دفعت الروس
لاستغلال هذا الاستفزاز في سحق او في
انتزاع اراضي من اوكرانيا فانت عليك بتدير
لو كان عندك القوه العسكريه انك تمنع
الروس كان يبقى افضل بس لو ما عندكش
النتيجه ان انت سمحت للامريكان ان هم
يستخدموك سكيب جوت او كبش فداء زي ما
دلوقتي فرنسا بتقول لهم ان هم عاوزين
يستخدموا تايوان كبش فداء في ادارهم
للصراع مع الصين هم كمان استخدموا
اوكرانيا تخيل معي الحرب دي تخلص باي
نتيجه
خلصت بخساره روسيا وان الجيش انقلب على
بوتين وانه اعدموه في ميدان عام انا بقول
اي كلام يعني وانه خلاص واصبح زيلينسكي
بطلا قوميا ايه اللي هيحصل لاوكرانيا يعني
اوكرانيا هتحتاج الى مئات المليارات من
الدولارات للاعمار ما حدش هيدفع لهم حاجه
واذا دفعوا يدفعوا على مدار 300 400 سنه
وهتبقى ديون
وعمل ما تعمر اوكرانيا يبتدوا يفتح حالها
كل ملفاتها ملف بقى الشفافيه اعاده بناء
الدوله والشفافيه والديمقراطيه
هتكون روسيا اعيد بنائها مره تانيه وانقضت
على اوكرانيا وقت طلعتها من جذورها سامحني
اذا كان رايي متطرف في المساله هو مش
متطرف من وجهه نظري هو صريح يعني
لان الحياه مش تقف عند بوتين بوتين هينتهي
بوتين عنده 70 سنه هيعيش كمان ايه في
الحكم كام اربع سنوات خمس سنوات عشر سنوات
روسيا مصدر للمشاكل والخلاف مع الغرب من
يعني عشرات السنوات
هيعملوا الدوله مساحتها 17 اكتر من 17
مليون كيلو متر مربع اعملوا ايه مع دوله
فيها الاف الرؤوس النوويه فيها عشرات
الالاف من العلماء فيها
ثروات ضخمه جدا كل العالم محتاجها هيودوها
فين من الخريطه يعني
سيد قبائل كلامك عن عوده العلاقات مع
الاسد قبل اكثر من سنه اصلب اصاب الواقع
اليوم واثبت انك
محلل جدا ممتاز سعيد شكرا جزيلا اخونا
حسين علي هل من المعقول ان يتم تعويض ده
سؤال تاني من مروان هل من المعقول ان يتم
تعويم بشار الاسد بعد كل هذه الجرائم ده
احنا اجبناها لماذا هناك مشاكل اجبناها
بين ايران
الامريكان تستطيع تمويل كل الجبهات
العسكريه مثل اوكرانيا والتضييق على تركيا
ومجابهه الصين وكثير من المواقع الجغرافيه
الحرجه
ما هو ده السؤال اللي شغل الامريكان على
مدار قرن كامل نتدخل في العالم الخارجي
ولا لا نتدخل فيه
انا تناولت القصه دي في حلقه على التوجهات
المختلفه موقف الامريكان من العالم
الخارجي انا ممكن استخدمكم ان انا يعني
اعيد نشرها مره تانيه لانها بتشرح الخلاف
اللي موجود في امريكا منذ سنوات طويله جدا
مره تانيه لكن الاجابه على سؤالك لا قبل
مش قادره يعني كانت الاول قادره لما كان
عندها قدرات كبيره دلوقتي اقتصادها اقل
مما كان شهيتها لدخول صراعات مع دول اصبحت
اقوى ايضا من مكان اصبحت اقل الصراع مكلف
ودول صغيره بالنسبه لامريكا
بتكلفها كثيرا ايران بالنسبه لامريكا ولا
حاجه بس هي تدرك ان الدخول الحرب مع ايران
مثلا هيكون مكلف جدا قد يقضي على
الامبراطوريه الامريكيه كلها لانه
هيستنزفها وهيدي فرصه لدول زي الصين ان هي
تتجاوزها ودوله زي روسيا انه يخف الضغط
عنها لا يعني هي مش قادره
ما اغبى تعليقات ليه كده المتابعين ليه
المتابعين المحلل يتكلم في موضوع سياسي
تريند ونحن في طريق اخر لا يعني عاوزين
يسالوا اخونا سما يعني
مش تعليقاتهم حاجات شغلاهم انا طبعا كان
نفسي اتكلم في الوثائق اكثر وانا كنت
ذاكرت يعني واخدت نوتس كتيره بس
انتم كنت متوقع هتهتموا بمساله التسريبات
اكتر خلاص ممكن نعملها حلقه ان شاء الله
اذا ربنا احيانا بكره باذن الله
لا هقول دي في الاخر يعني مساله الحلقات
او ممكن انسى بالمناسبه ناس بيسالوني انا
ليه
بقيت اعمل حلقات قصيره مؤخرا
انا ما عملتش حلقات قصيره مؤخرا اللي حصل
ان انا
الاسباب يطول شرحها يعني وانا مشغول
بالتحضير لحلقات جايه كتيره ان شاء الله
ربنا يحينا شهر مايو مقبل في احداث كتيره
قوي في الانتخابات التركيه في اجتماع
جامعه الدول العربيه في ذكرى المشؤومه
لقيام دوله اسرائيل الخمسه وسبعين
والاحداث الكثيره في اسرائيل واحداث مهمه
جدا جدا بيحصل تغيرات جوهريه في اسرائيل
هتاثر علينا وعلى العالم كله وفي ملفات
اخرى وتطورات الحرب فانا مشغول بعد
الحلقات ديت من الناحيه ومن الناحيه
التانيه انه بيجي لي اسئله عاوزه اجابه
الاجابات دي انا جاوبت عنها في حلقات
سابقه او حاولت للاجابه عنها فبجد ان
الاجابات موجوده في جزء من حلقه يعني مثلا
الحلقه اللي انا مش انا ناسي اسامي
الحلقات مثلا حلقه بتقول استراتيجيه
ايران ايه وليه ايران ما فضلتش الرد على
اسرائيل فدول كانوا عباره عن ست او سبعه
دقائق في حلقه حوالي 30 دقيقه بتتكلم في
موضوعات مختلفه
فخدت السبع دقايق دول معي ماندو ولا نمت
والله خدت السبع دقايق دول واخدتهم اجابه
على سؤال حد بيطرحه بدل ما اقعدوا مره
تانيه السؤال لما حد سال عن الازمه ما هو
في متابعين جدد الحمد لله حد يسال ايه قصه
تايوان تلات دقايق بيشرحوا القصه دي حد
وهكذا كل المقاطع القصيره ديت هي كانت
عباره عن اجزاء في حلقات بترد على اسئله
محدده واظن انه هي لقت قبول من الناس طبعا
في ناس شافوها قبل كده فلا يشاهدوها او مش
عاوزين يشوفوها للمره الثانيه وفي ناس
بيشوفوها للمره الاولى ونشفوها قبل كده
وارادوا ان هم يروها مره اخرى وبضع تحت
الحلقه بقول يمكنكم متابعه الحلقه كامله
وبدا رابط واستاذنكم
انه انتم تبصوا على اسفل الحلقه لانه
بعيدا عن المقاطع القصيره اللي انا بكتب
فيها كده في كل حلقه بيكون فيها المصادر
والملاحظه عن الحلقه
اذا كانت اعيد نشرها قبل كده او الدائم
بقى اللي مع كل الحلقات الجديده والقديمه
انا بكتب مصادر الحلقه المصادر اللي كل
معلومه انا بقولها ببقى حريص على كتابه
المصدر فيها انا اسف ان انا خدتكم على
سؤال لم تطرحوه قلقان يعني لكن انتم
طرحتوه برسائل كثيره
مساء الخير استاذ سيد احد الجنرات الروسي
يهدد بضرب الموانئ والمطارات البولنديه
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالسلحه لهذا ممكن لا
مش ممكن هتبقى حرب بين روسيا وحلف شمال
الاطلسي
ده فوزي
يعني ممكن بمعنى انه يكون تصعيد يعني تبقى
حرب مباشره بقى يعني مش مستتره لماذا دول
الخليج ساهموا في غزو العراق ومن بعد ذلك
يعني حاجه ايران يعني يلومون ايران والله
دول الخليج مش كيان واحد لكن انا في حدود
معلوماتي انه الدول الخليجيه واذكر دلوقتي
وانت بتكلمني على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
عارضت الغزو وحذرت منه وكان لهم تصريحات
علنيه برفض الغزو واذكر دول اخرى رفضت لكن
الولايات المتحده ارادت وفعلت
ما اقدرش اقول ان في تناقض يا علي اسرائيل
ستضرب قلناها عادل هل بدات اوروبا التحرر
من القبضه الامريكيه لا لم تبدا لكن لكن
التغيرات اللي بقى لها سنتين تلاته وخصوصا
مع الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا مش بعيد ان اوروبا وهم عندهم
يعني ما هماش كائنات مهياش دول جمهوريه
الموز هيبقى في تغييرات كبيره في سياستها
اللي استقرت منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والى الان اللي يعني اجابه على
سؤالك انه ممكن يبتدوا يعددوا اوراقهم وهم
مشكلتهم كله في الجانب العسكري انه يجدوا
صيغه ان هم يامنوا انفسهم بعيدا عن الجيش
الامريكي هم ما عندهمش مشاكل في الاقتصاد
وبالتالي ما عندهمش مشاكل في
اذا تحرروا عسكريه من امريكا انه يكون
عندهم سياسه مستقله
لماذا لا يوجد هيئه محايده وغير سياسيه
تجمع نخبه علماء الاديان الثلاثه بدون
تبعيه لاي جهه او منظمه او حزب ويبحث
ويدرسوا التاريخ الديني ما الاخطاء التي
يمارسها البشر وشرح المشاكل المتعلقه
بينهم
يعني
انا يعني ده مش موضوع الحقيقه انا ما
اعرفش انه في ناس بيعملوا كده ولكن حتى
لما عملوا كده وجوه ضغوط شديده لانه دايما
المشاريع من النوع ده ما بيكونش بريء
والمشروع الابراهيمي
اللي الدكتوره هبه جمال الدين صديقتنا
قادر اتكلمت عنه كان بيقوم على فكره انه
العلماء يجتمعوا من كل الاديان ويحاولوا
يقربوا وجهات النظر يعني انما في حاجه
تانيه احب اقول لك عليها انا يعني ما
عنديش اهتمام كبير بهذه القضيه لكن اللي
انا رقبته واللي انا شفته واللي انا واثق
منه ان لا يمكن اي دوله تترك للاعلام
كله كده يغرد منفردا ولا رجال الدين لازم
تسعى للسيطره على رجال الدين لازم تسعى
للسيطره على الاعلام هل كل رجل دي مسيطر
عليه لا هي عاوزه يكون عندها ما تسيبش
رجال الدين انفلتوا بالكامل ويقول اللي هم
عاوزينه ممكن يقبضوا الدوله بالكامل فلازم
تسعى للسيطره على المؤسسات الدينيه ولازم
تسعى للمسيطره على المسلسلات الاعلاميه
اذا فشلت في السيطره على كل المؤسسات فعلى
الاقل تسيطر على اكبر عدد من هذه المؤسسات
السلام عليكم ممكن حلقه بتشرح
السؤال لحضرتك هل تتوقع
انفراجه في الازمه الدولانيه المصريه وهل
تتوقع تعويم اخر ولا اي مدى هيكون السعر
المتوقع
والله انا يعني حتى الان حتى هذه اللحظه
المؤشرات ما بتقولش ان في انفراجه قريبه
ليه لانه كان في تفاوضات مع الصندوق هذه
المفاوضات حتى الان فيها صعوبه في اتمامها
زي بالظبط ما حدث الى حد كبير في تونس ان
في تاخر في الاتفاق زي ما حصل في باكستان
معنى ذلك ان في خلاف ما بين الصندوق وما
بين الحكومه المصريه عندهم رؤى مختلفه ما
دام في تاخر يبقى هيكون في تاخر فيه
القروض التي سوف تاتي اللي هي تحل المشكله
ولو مؤقتا
ايضا لا يوجد اتفاق واضح حتى هذه اللحظه
بقول حتى هذه اللحظه ليه لانه ممكن تكون
في اتفاقات تعرف العقليه العربيه برضو
فيها بعد يعني شخص كتير يعني ممكن خلال 48
ساعه يحصل اتفاق ما بين الحكومه المصريه
ودول الخليجيه عندها فائض زي السعوديه زي
الامارات زي قطر زي الكويت قول والله احنا
هنضخ استثمارات ب 30 مليار دولار تتحل كل
المشاكل مثلا 30 مليار ما هوش رقم ضخم جدا
ويتفاوض على الامور اللي هم مختلفين فيها
واللي تعطل ضخ هذه الاموال هم عندهم
تصورات للتاكد من ان في عائد كبيره تاتي
على اموالهم والحكومه المصريه عندها
اولويات
حتى الان لا يوجد شيء معلن يقول ان الازمه
تتحل خلال اسبوع 10 ايام شهرين لا عن طريق
الصندوق ولا عن طريق التفاوض مع دول
الخليج او الدول اللي عندها فائض زي الصين
ده معلوماتي قد اكون الصوره مش واضحه لي
انا بتكلم على المعلن غير المعلن لا اعلم
عنه شيء
الجزء التاني من السؤال هل تتوقع تعويم
اخر هي مشكله التعويم يعويمه يعني اعمل
ايه الدولار دلوقتي في السوق الرسمي اظن
حوالي 31 جنيه مش كده يعني 30 وشويه صح
نقول 31
طيب بس في سوق موازي اظن اخر مره سمعت كان
35 طيب نفترض انه عوامه عوامه بقى ايه في
السوق الرسمي بقى بدل 31 خلاه اربعين طيب
ما كده برضو انا عندي المشكله انا هجيب
الدولارات منين اللي اسند بها هو برضو
عنده مشكله ان السلعه نفسها مش متوفره
اللي هي الدولار احتياج مصر للدولار ما
تحتاجه اكثر مما يدخل اليها لاسباب كثيره
واحد اتنين تلاته اربعه خمسه سته فهنا
عمليه التعويم تبقى مجديه لو انا بدا يدخل
عندي دولارات الدولارات دي عشان تدخل انا
محتاج الحاجات اللي على الامد الطويله
هتحتاج وقت طويل اللي هو استثمارات
واصلاحات وتيجي استثمارات مباشره والعالم
كله لازم يكون منتعش ده مش صعب ده اولا
صعب ويحتاج كتير طيب عاوز قروض القروض
تجيء لك منين القروض تجيلك اللي من دور
اتفاق الصندوق النقد الدولي ان يجي لك
اموال ساخنه الاموال الساخنه ومش هتجيلك
طالما انت الفايده في امريكا خمسه في
الميه واحتمال تقفز لسته في الميه فهيجي
هنا يسلفك ليه وانت عنده بياخد 5% وهو
ضامن فلوسه في الولايات المتحده الفائده
قفزت من زيرو الى 5% انت الاموال الساخنه
بتجيلك لما تكون الفايده في امريكا النص
واحد ومصر بتقدم له تلاته اربعه لكن
امريكا بتقدم له خمسه
مصر وكل الدول اللي هي محتاجه فلوس ما
تقدرش تجاري الولايات المتحده وتقول له
طيب تعالى وانا ادي لك 12% مش هتقدر
وبالتالي الاموال الساخنه وحتى لو قالت له
اللي عندهم الاموال الساخنه ديت يقول لك
طب انا اجي اسلف مصر ولا باكستان ولا
تركيا ما في احتمال انه ما يقدروش يسددوا
فيبقى انا خسرت فلوسك فبيفضل طوبار كدماني
يحط الفلوس في البنوك الامريكيه فاضل انه
يروح للصندوق الصندوق بيطلب منه شروط